going everybody it's warren welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk
everything marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and
yesterday we got one division episode
four
the most revealing episode so far of one
division if you have not seen episode 4
or any of the other episodes there are
going to be some spoilers in this video
for episodes 1 through 4.
now episode 4 was revealing but of
course we still have many different
questions
and are left with even more but we do
know that sword are indeed the people
watching
wanda and the rest of the people stuck
inside of this energy bubble
they are not responsible for putting her
inside of it and they are not
experimenting on her which were some
theories out there and at the end of the
episode
monica rambo said that it was all wanda
she was inside this energy bubble
different reality
she came outside and when she came out
she said wanda was responsible for
everything however i'm not really buying
that and if you want to know how i feel
you can check out the breakdown of
episode 4 that i did yesterday but today
i want to talk about something that is
extremely important to the future of the
one division series something that
marvel just
barely slipped in a tiny little easter
egg that actually
reveals a lot in episode 4 sword starts
to realize
that real people are indeed in this
bubble reality monica rambo being one of
them
so sword gets to work and they start to
id all of the different characters or
cast members as they call them in the
show and they try to figure out who they
are
and where they're from in real life and
they start to do this and they get one
character and then another character
until eventually they have pretty much
almost everybody but one thing they do
is they write
notes about each character and how they
kind of behave
around wanda and vision and one
character that they got
a lot of details about is abalash
tandon's character
norm norm is the person who works with
vision at his job
and he also had contact with him at the
neighborhood watch and other places as
well that i'm sure we didn't see
but something very important to look at
is what it says
in the notes about him if you freeze
frame episode 4 at
1807 you can zoom in and see what it
says
and it reads abulash expresses concern
for his father and sister this
information
was obtained when vision awakened him is
wanda controlling a whole town
physical safety of residents is now in
question
when vision releases him abalash becomes
norm again now this is an extremely
important factor of one division because
it shows us that
vision actually has the power to snap
people
out of this trance or spell whatever is
put over them that makes them
not remember their normal life vision
has the power to get rid of that and it
allows people to become
normal again but it also shows us that
vision has the power to take that away
as well
so they turn back into their characters
but this is going to be a key moving
forward in order to save the town and
the people inside of it
and we already know that vision himself
kind of snaps out of everything at one
point in time due to the trailers and tv
spots that we've seen
and although we didn't see him awaken
abulash we've actually
seen him awaken agnes in one of the
trailers that we got i believe it was
the first trailer that we got
he touches agnes and she awakens and she
asks herself
am i dead he says no why would you say
that and she says because you are so
she remembers life outside of this new
reality
vision awakened her and he most likely
did this
with the mind stone it looks like he
uses the mind stone
in the trailer to awaken agnes and he
most likely uses it to awaken
other people as well and as i mentioned
at one point he's going to become
completely aware of what is happening
and we've even seen
in a recent tv spot that vision manages
to
escape as we can see from these stills
right here vision
ends up finding the bubble he finds the
end of the energy field and he actually
manages to get out
now from here we can assume that sword
is going to find him they're going to
question him he's going to question them
because he's probably not going to
entirely know what's going on
but we can probably assume that he's
going to go back in because juan is
going to wonder where he is
now the question of his vision alive or
dead is still kind of unclear
but regardless of whether or not he's
alive right now i do think he's going to
become alive if you noticed when monika
rambo
went inside of the bubble reality her
clothes changed the energy force field
adapted them to fit the reality but when
she was kicked out her clothes remained
the same
in the comics wanda brought some
characters back to life in a different
reality and then when that reality was
gone they remained alive
that could be what we're seeing right
here vision may be dead in the main
reality but wanda has created a new
reality and he is seemingly alive in
this new reality so
when he crosses over which it looks like
he does and we see it in the tv spot
that could make him alive in our actual
reality
and again from there he's probably going
to talk to sword and realize what's
going on
then go back in and that's where things
kind of get a little tricky sword has
realized that he has the power to awaken
people inside of this reality and
they're probably going to ask him to
help
awaken the people and free them but
wanda herself
isn't exactly awakened and whenever she
seemingly does get awakened
she goes back to this perfect reality
because of course she does
if you have found yourself suddenly
living the dream life you're not going
to want to change it
and this is the complicated part wanda
is most likely not going to want
anything to change
and if she sees her husband changing the
reality around her that's probably not
good
but you also have to keep in mind that
vision loves wanda and will probably do
anything for her after all if my theory
is correct that wanda has created a new
vision and when he crosses over into the
main reality he becomes
alive again this vision is more
emotional than the previous one we've
seen that
all throughout episodes one through four
we have an emotional
more human vision so he may not want to
actually help sword he may want to give
his wife the reality that she wants
but unfortunately and ultimately
everything will start to fall apart
because we know that there is another
force out there
the real villain either mephisto agatha
harkness the grim reaper
hydra somebody out there is eventually
going to intervene with the whole entire
thing if not an enemy
sword is going to take matters into
their own hands to try and save the
people
and based off what we've seen in tv
spots and the trailers it looks like
this
does happen at one point or another in a
recent special clip we see a sword truck
bursting into the bubble going inside of
the reality
and then in another clip we hear wanda
say this is our home and vision says
let's protect it this lets us know that
somebody
either sword hydra or another force is
going to come inside of this reality and
threaten it and try to take it away from
wanda
and it does seem like at some points
vision is kind of under a little spell
as well he does have the power to break
out of it but sometimes he falls under
it whether it's wanda's doing mephisto's
doing or somebody else he does fall
under it but when he's out
he's very aware and he has that ability
to awaken other people
and ultimately this will be the key to
saving the town
and wanda wanda has to snap out of this
fake
perfect reality it's not real now does
that mean that she may have to fight
vision at one point in time
yes i believe she will and it kind of
looks like we've seen that in some
photos released
and another important factor to consider
is if my theory is correct
about things being recreated
reincarnated whatever you want to call
it
in this new reality crossing over into
the real reality become real
like vision being alive in this reality
and then going into the other one and
staying
alive that means that the mind stone is
going to come back as well so in the
future we could see the return of
not only some but all of the infinity
stones and we do know that doctor
strange
will probably show up in one of vision
but if not one division connects to dr
strange and he may see this as an
opportunity to bring back the time stone
we'll have to wait and see on that and
if i figure anything out i'll be sure to
let everybody know so don't forget to
subscribe with the notifications turned
on so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos also be sure to let me
know what you think about vision's
ability to
awaken people do you think he's going to
be the key to helping everybody in the
town and ultimately
saving wanda let me know in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
always follow me on instagram and
twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof